basada en un informe encargado en
españa' la fiscalía general de bolivia
ha decidido cerrar el caso denominado
fraude electoral y ha pedido el
sobreseimiento de todos los acusados la
mayoría de ellos vocales electorales que
el año 2019 han sido acusados de
manipular los datos electorales en favor
del entonces candidato evo morales- la
fiscalía para tomar esta decisión ha
pedido a la fundación general de la
universidad de salamanca que haga una
pericia sobre estas elecciones
este informe acaba de llegar a bolivia y
ha establecido que si bien hubo
negligencia en el manejo de los
resultados electorales no se puede decir
que hubo manipulación el ex presidente
carlos mesa que fue el directo
contenedor de evo morales ha calificado
este informe de poco creíble
extemporáneo y además ha señalado que ha
sido elaborado a la medida del
movimiento al socialismo hay que
recordar que la acusación de fraude
electoral estaba basada en un informe de
la organización de estados américanos
que el año 2019 realizó
una auditoría en bolivia y dijo que hubo
fraude electoral